There are only three types of
copywriting that you should focus on in
2025.
First is social media advertisements,
second is emails, and third is landing
pages. And the reason you should only
focus on one of these three, or full
stack these three, is because they are
the only ones that have conversion
metrics attached to them. Meaning, you
can track whether your copy sold
something or didn't sell something.
Things like blog writing and social
media ghostwriting are completely dead
because the metrics attached to that
style of copywriting is likes and
followers. And your customers and
clients don't care about likes and
followers, they care about cash, sales.
So, emails sell, landing pages sell, and
ads sell. Focus on those three and
you'll get higher paying clients, you'll
make a lot more money yourself. There
are only three types of copywriting that
you should focus on in 2025.